foreign
hey what's up guys I'm Dave Rubin this
is the Reuben report direct message for
today July 20th 2021 uh do me a favor
subscribe to our YouTube channel tap the
notification Bell share our videos and
all that good stuff only three stories
for you today we're mixing it up a
little of everything uh first off there
is this incredible really incredible
compilation video of Democrats over the
past couple years complaining about uh
voter hacking and voting machines not
working and election Integrity problems
and all that sort of stuff of course
it's all pre this election now we're not
allowed to talk about that there is a
good chance I will be booted off YouTube
or at least get a strike for doing this
video today if so please join us at
reubenreport.locals.com because we are
going to show you this compilation video
these are all public officials making
statements of their own volition so uh
YouTube uh Gods that are watching this
right now please do don't shut us down
these are Democrats saying these things
I know these are things you were allowed
to say before this election you're not
allowed to say anymore we're just going
to play them and let their words stand
on their own part two this is breaking
right now there is a hearing in
Washington DC a more wretched Hive of
scum and villainy you will not find but
Rand Paul Senator Rand Paul from
Kentucky who obviously is one of the few
politicians that I think is a pretty
decent guy son of uh Ron Paul of course
and really the only I would say true
libertarian Senator I would say Ted Cruz
is kind of close but Rand Paul I would
say is probably mostly in line with the
types of views that I espouse on this
show he really got into it with Dr
Anthony fauci today the infallible fauci
over this gain of function research that
was happening in the Wuhan lab I'm going
to explain what gain of function is
we're going to show you about a
three-minute clip of them going back and
forth basically calling each other liars
and I'll try to unpack it in a sensible
way I think it's important to show you
this three-minute clip because we need
some context here because basically Rand
Paul is saying that we through grants
funded the research at Wuhan lab which
then used gain of function research
which basically takes animal disease and
manipulates it in essence so that it can
be spread to humans and that we sort of
funded this whole thing and that fauci
has something to do with that you'll see
how fauci kind of bounces around and
sort of you'll see his very technical
bureaucratic way of speaking but he
doesn't completely deny the gain a
function thing which is sort of
interesting because he was pretty much
denying it a few weeks ago and then
finally
we're going to talk a little bit about
Cuba and socialism and of course that
will involve AOC and the 1619 project
and everything else which it's sort of
nice what's happening right now the
Democrats are doing exactly what I said
they would do I mean I started saying
this a couple years ago when when Bernie
and the crew when they were saying
they're Democratic socialists right
we're Democrat socialists and I kept
saying to everybody well they're going
to drop Democrats soon enough and isn't
it interesting you don't hear them say
it anymore right they say they're
progressives but they don't really say
they're Democrats and they don't really
say that they're full socialists but
that's it's pretty much coming and we've
got some audio and some tweets to prove
it guys before I get to any of that I
want to talk to you about Bonner private
wine I've got some mileback right here
here's a tip for you next time you grill
up a couple of steaks pop open a bottle
of extreme altitude Malbec wine it comes
from these remote Vineyards in Argentina
located up at around 9000 feet when
these Vintners aren't making wine
they're herding cattle so they they know
meat they know barbecue and that's what
these malbecs are for as soon as you
open the bottle you're going to
experience delicious notes of blackberry
leather smoke and a little dark cherry
you're also getting less sugar less
chemicals and additives and 10 times
more Resveratrol which is a powerful
longevity booster we're actually busting
out a rib eye tonight I will be putting
pictures at Ruben report.locals.com and
I will be drinking some extreme Malbec
wine the guys over at
freethinkerwine.com just got a special
shipment of these Wines in they've got
one Malbec from the third highest
Vineyard in the world at almost nine
thousand feet visit freethinkerwine.com
today and you'll get 50 off the wine and
50 off shipping this is a small batch
and it's going to go fast just visit
freethinkerwine.com that's
freethinkerwine.com and now back to me
all right let's just get right into the
stories so first this incredible
compilation video has been making its
way around the Twitter and I hope that
you good people are trying to stay sane
through all this madness and you're not
spending too much time on Twitter so we
thought we'd show it to you we got a
whole bunch of Democrats Circa 2018
basically saying everything about voter
fraud and voter machines and error and
manipulation and everything else pretty
much everything that Mike Lindell the
pillow guy you know Mr pillow he's
always hugging a pillow loves Donald
Trump pretty much everything he's been
saying about this past election well
that's pretty much what they were all
saying when it came to talking about
what might have happened in 2016 and
what they're going to have to do going
forward take a look-see I continue to
think that our voting machines are too
vulnerable but research is have
repeatedly demonstrated that ballot
recording machines and other voting
systems are susceptible to tempering
even hackers with limited prior
knowledge tools and resources are able
to breach voting machines in a matter of
minutes in 2018 electronic voting
machines in Georgia and Texas deleted
votes for certain candidates or switch
votes from one candidate to another the
biggest seller of voting machines is
doing something that violates cyber
security 101 directing that you install
remote access software which would make
a machine like that you know a magnet
for fraudsters and hackers these voting
machines can be hacked quite easily you
could easily hack into them it makes it
seem like all these states are doing
different things but in fact three
companies are controlling this it is the
individual voting machines that some
pose that pose some of the greatest
risks there are a lot of states that are
dealing with Antiquated machines
right which are vulnerable to being
hacked workers were able to easily hack
into electronic voting machine it was
possible to switch votes 43 of American
voters use voting machines that
researchers have found have serious
security flaws including back doors we
know how vulnerable now our systems were
we know I know the hackathon that took
place last year where virtually every
machine was broken into fairly quickly I
actually held a demonstration for my
colleagues here at the Capitol where we
brought in folks who before our eyes
hacked election machines those that are
not those that are being used in many
states aging systems also frequently
rely on unsupported software like
Windows XP in 2000 which may not receive
regular security patches and are thus
more vulnerable to the latest methods of
Cyber attack in a close present election
they just need to hack one swing state
or maybe one or two or maybe just a few
counties in one swing state I'm very
concerned that you could have a hack
that finally went through
oh Mama Mia all right so just to be
clear if you were to say any of the
things that all of those Democrats and
those are not random Democrats right
like this video is not of just like
Democrats you ain't never heard of this
stuff this video is of Ted Lou this
video is Amy Klobuchar this video is
Kamala Harris like these are mainstream
Democrats okay people that are they're
good people they're better people than
we are right because I know you're a
right-wing Maniac just like I am uh if
you were to say any of the things that
they were saying back in 2018 or
basically before the 2020 election if I
was to say any of those things right now
related to the 2020 election my channel
would be deleted like we'd get a strike
we'd get a second strike and strike and
we'd just be blown away but not only
that if you were to say any of those
things in your circles in your Social
Circles I wonder what your friends would
say they would say you're a conspiracy
theorist you've been watching too much
Alex Jones or something like that and
that that's why this is all deeply
dangerous the very same things that
people were saying over the last couple
months like oh could things have been
hacked into maybe you wouldn't need
widespread fraud you just need it in
select places which is what Ted Lou said
there that you'd be able to switch votes
that that could be done there are back
doors to get into the voting machines
they can be easily hacked that was Ted
Lou and Amy Klobuchar said that we have
aging systems uh Kamala they're
vulnerable to a attack she even had a
bunch of people in a room and they had
hackers do it right in front of them
anyway I'm not saying that this last
election was hacked I'm just saying we
should be allowed to talk about all of
these things and when Democrats are on
the outs meaning we have a republican
Administration we had orange man for
those four years they were allowed to
say everything they wanted to say to
make it seem like either the eject the
election was illegitimate or if he was
to be re-elected that that election
would be illegitimate or hacked or
whatever you want to call it now if
we're to say anything you you would be
kicked out of your country club and
potentially kicked out of YouTube so
do it that what you will I just thought
it was important to play it's like
there's there's something there like so
I just wanted to like have you guys
fixed all that stuff because I know that
there's a bunch of Republican bills in a
bunch of uh States right now that are
trying to fix some of these
vulnerabilities uh as you guys know we
talked about the Texas Bill last week
and they want things like Paper Trails
so that if a machine was hacked there
would actually it wouldn't all be
digital there would actually be paper
lit or a paper trail is what it's called
there would be a long readout like an
actual paper receipt of what happened
but they don't seem to want that and
they don't seem to want cameras in the
rooms where people will be doing the
double counting and they don't seem to
want signature verification to confirm
that the person who voted is actually
who they say they are so you know call
me a crazy nut bad conspiracy theorist
but do these people want free and fair
elections or do they just want to win
elections which one do you think it is
and as I try to say in all of these
things that doesn't make the Republicans
perfect or great or right but they're
better than those people and I'm not a
Republican pollster or on the Dole of
the Republicans but if you want a slogan
Republicans if the Republican leadership
if you're watching this show all you
need to do Republicans 2024 we're not
those guys and that's what would be the
winning ticket like these people are all
crazy they're all crazy because they say
things and then when they get the power
that they have they reverse everything
that they're saying so actually perfect
segue into the next uh the next story so
uh Senator Rand Paul got into a massive
blowout with Dr fauci over covid this
morning so this has just happened in the
last hour or so we're going to show you
about a three minute clip here and
originally when I pulled the clip I
wanted to maybe cut it a little bit
you'll see a flash or two in there but
basically I wanted to give you guys
three minutes of really listen to what
the debate is really listen like I know
it's a little bit Technical and I'll
I'll give you the full definition of
what gain of function is after but
really listen to what Rand Paul is
accusing Dr fauci of and then listen to
what Dr fauci says in her response it's
quite extraordinary and I would just
paint one other thing I don't I don't
want to color your uh impression of this
too much but especially towards the end
listen to how Rand Paul is using a lot
of bureaucratic language instead of
giving just a clear answer did we fund
gain a function uh list you know just
listen to how fauci is sort of
obfuscating what the answer might be all
right take a look Dr falci as you are
aware it is a crime to lie to Congress
section one zero zero one of the U.S
criminal code creates a felony in a
five-year penalty for lying to Congress
on your last trip to our committee on
May 11th you stated that the NIH has not
ever and has not now fund gain of
function research in the Wuhan Institute
of virology
and yet
gain of function research was done
entirely in the Wuhan Institute by Dr
she and was funded by the NIH in this
paper Dr she credits the NIH and lists
the actual number of the grant that she
was given by the NIH
in this paper she took two bat
coronavirus genes Spike genes and
combined them with a SARS related
backbone to create new viruses that are
not found in nature these lab-created
viruses were then to Shone to replicate
in humans
these experiments combine genetic
information from different coronaviruses
that infect animals but not humans to
create novel artificial viruses able to
infect human cells
viruses that in nature only infect
animals were manipulated in the Wuhan
lab to gain the function of infecting
humans This research fits the definition
of the research that the NIH said was
subject to the pause in 2014 to 2017 a
pause in funding on gain of function the
Wuhan lab used NIH funding to construct
novel chimeric SARS related
coronaviruses able to infect human cells
and laboratory animals this is high risk
research that creates new potential
pandemic pathogens potential pandemic
pathogens that exist only in the lab not
in nature This research matches these
are Dr E Bright's words this research
matches indeed epitomizes the definition
of gain of function research done
entirely in Wuhan
for which there was supposed to be a
federal pause
Dr fauci knowing that it is a crime to
lie to Congress do you wish to retract
your statement of May 11th where you
claimed that the NIH never funded gain
of function research in Wuhan senator
Paul I have never lied before the
Congress and I do not retract that
statement this paper that you are
referring to was judged by qualified
staff up and down the chain as not being
gained of function what was let me
finish Shake an animal virus and you
increase his responsibility to humans
right you're saying that's not gain a
function that is correct and and senator
Paul you do not know what you are
talking about quite frankly and I want
to say that officially you do not know
what you are talking about okay you get
one person that's read from the Niah
is that the the grant that was funded as
a sub award from Eco Health to Wuhan
created sauce cov2 that's where you are
getting let me finish we don't know well
wait a minute I come to the lab but all
the evidence is pointing that it came
from the lab and there will be
responsibility for those who funded the
lab including yourself I totally this
community will allow the witness to I
totally resent the lie that you are now
propagating Senator because if you look
at the viruses that were used in the
experiments that were given in the
annual reports that were published in
the literature it is molecularly
impossible no one's saying though it is
positive it is
virus caused the pandemic what we're
alleging is that gain of function
research was going on in that lab and
NIH funded it that is not away from it
it meets your definition and you are
obfuscating the truth
okay so I hope you guys understand why I
showed you the full clip there because
you can sort of see fauci at the end
trying to well we funded this and the
paper that did this that the other thing
he's giving you a lot of bureaucratic
stuff there so previously he had
actually said that the NIH the National
Institute of Health never funded gain of
function research in the Wuhan lab
Rand Paul is now saying that is exactly
what you did and we have evidence of it
so I can't sit here and tell you that I
know which the truth is on that fauci's
saying well fauci's not exactly saying
they didn't do it anymore right he's
just saying the funding may have went to
something else that was like sort of
ancillarially involved but not exactly
so let's just pause on that for a second
just let's just be clear about one thing
Rand Paul is making a very specific
accusation the NIH funded gain of
function research in the Wuhan lab
that's the accusation fauci last time he
was under oath and that's why Rand Paul
worded it the way he did last time he
was under oath said that's absolutely
untrue this time he didn't quite exactly
say that but I thought I'd give you guys
a clean definition of what gain of
function is Rand Paul explained it I
thought quite well but I thought if I
could just give you the cleanest
possible explanation because this is all
technical stuff I'm not an expert in
this I know you're not an expert in this
but we need to know we need to know like
some Basics about this right so we when
you have a conversation with friends and
family and they're talking about all of
this stuff and lab leaks and everything
else that you have some ability to
communicate some of this stuff so gain
of function research involves
experimentation that aims or is expected
to and or perhaps actually does increase
the transmissibility and or virulence of
pathogens such research when conducted
by responsible scientists usually aims
to improve understanding of
disease-causing Agents their
interactions with human hosts and or
their potential to cause pandemics
despite these important potential
benefits benefits gain of function
research can pose risks regarding
biosecurity and biosafety so basically
they meddle with these viruses and then
the argument that Rand Paul is making is
then it can basically jump to humans and
then if that then leaks out of the lab
we have a problem so on the technical
part of this right like just the legal
part if fauci lied under oath that the
NIH was actually funding gain of
function research at the Wuhan lab well
then fauci's in some trouble so he never
fully denied it there and I think that
that is pretty interesting he's saying
oh the thing that we funded through the
grant that went to the thing and it's
like that's just what perfect
bureaucratic answers are right like
there's always some eight you know 87
layers from the truth
um I think the bigger issue right now
basically is like how do we figure out
who to trust and how is it I mean that's
what I was thinking when I was like all
right we got to cover this right because
this is a massive blowout between a
senator who I think is a decent guy
fauci who I I don't think fauci's a
horrible human being I think he's
probably in over his head I think he's
made a lot of mistakes along the way I
don't think this was an easy job he is
the highest paid person in the federal
government and everything else but again
we're in that information War where some
people are just going to be like all
right I believe fauci some people are
like all right I believe Rand Paul but
the simple truth here is if you lied
under oath he's in a lot of trouble and
we should know right like regardless of
what you think about covet at this point
regardless of what you think about
vaccines and everything else we should
know if it was our own uh NIH that was
funding this stuff right and then how
did it get out and did he know about it
and everything else and should we be
funding that sort of research as the
definition that I just read describes
there are some benefits to it because we
can figure out how diseases work and how
they jump from species and all of these
things again I'm not an expert in this
and I'm not pretending to be anything
other than I am but there's obviously
some benefits to gain a function
research but if then it can create
pathogens that are jumping to humans and
then there aren't perfect systems to
keep them in the lab and they can leak
out and cause like a I don't know
two-year shutdown of the world then we
got problems on our hand uh if you want
to know more about Rand Paul's feelings
about fouchy about whether the
government was involved in this and
everything else check out my interview
with Rand Paul back in March which why
don't we link to that in the description
we are a professional outfit over here I
think we can do that and uh you know
make some decisions for yourself but I
it's like I don't even know exactly what
to think of that segment you know I can
usually give you a pretty a pretty clear
opinion on what I think about things and
I'm guessing that you watching this
right now or feeling something very
similar it's like you know fauci got
very indignant I'm I'm very offended
basically I'm very very offended by what
you're accusing me of well that that
doesn't mean you didn't do it that just
means you're offended by it but also
Rand Paul was very clear in what he did
do you want to retract it now and and he
said no so we shall see we shall see uh
speaking of covid um okay we know that
the Delta variant is spreading okay I
think you guys all know my feelings on
covet at this point actually what you
know more clearly than my feelings on
covet well first off I believe that
covet exists I think I probably had
covid a couple weeks ago I know plenty
of people that had covid and recovered
from covid I know that a certain amount
of people over the age of 80 with all
the comorbidities and everything else
die I also know that because of
lockdowns and masks that rates of
depression are up that rates of suicide
are up that rates of alcoholism are up
at drug use and all of these things that
we've destroyed lives and that for the
most of us and most of you watching this
your lives were far more negatively
affected by government lockdowns and
other men mandates and orders by
centralized power and by governments
than they were by covid itself and even
if kovid was killing half the population
at what point is it no longer the
government's right to tell you you have
to stay in your house but it is your
right as a free individual on on the
planet Earth to live as you see fit and
knowing that there is some risk in the
world right like we all know that there
is some risk well in any event
a lot of people got vaccinated a lot of
people have not got vaccinated now
they're telling us that if you're
vaccinated it's not as perfect as they
thought you may need it every six month
booster shot and now they're also saying
that if you get the Delta variant that
you can still get covid but perhaps it
will be slightly less sick I would love
to find some more numbers on this like
there everyone's screaming about the
Delta variant right now is it affecting
younger people people under 80 are the
death rates much higher et cetera et
cetera well Australia I'm going to show
you two videos here from Australia
because Australia seems to be going into
Canadian like Draconian measures like
really really crazy stuff so first here
is a Australian public health expert and
if you want to see what fear-mongering
is like true government issued
fear-mongering take a look at this Wall
Street is in human nature to engage in
conversation with others to be friendly
unfortunately this is not the time to do
that so even if you run into your
next-door neighbor
in the shopping center in the Coles
whilst you're at Kohl's Wars or Aldi or
any other grocery shop
don't start up a conversation now is the
time for minimizing your interactions
with others even if you've got a mask
do not think that affords Total
Protection we want to be absolutely sure
that as we go about our daily lives we
do not come into contact with anyone
else that would pose a risk
as you go about your daily life you
don't want to come in contact with
anyone else that would cause a risk you
know every moment of everyone's life
they're doing just that you meet
somebody on the street they might punch
you in the face you walk outside a dog
might bite you might get hit by a car
you might get struck by lightning the
world might explode anything can be
possible there is some seriously evil
orwellian language right there do not
engage human beings or engage in
conversations do not engage in
conversations why would the government
not want people to engage in
conversations why would they want us to
not talk to each other at supermarkets
as she said and just limit that all to
online conversation you think there
might be a reason for that perhaps they
could manipulate that conversation a bit
more am I being a complete conspiracy
theorist here I mean that is scary scary
stuff this is also you know we played a
video a couple days ago who was the
woman I think it was a woman in New
Zealand if I'm not mistaken saying that
we are the exclusive source for truth it
was a health minister in New Zealand we
are the exclusive sorcerer truth the
number one source for truth man I mean
this is this is 1984 this is Hunger
Games this is every dystopian movie
you've ever seen well now check out this
video this is an Australian news channel
talking about new lockdowns that are
coming and look at the numbers look at
the numbers she's going to put them out
you can listen to her and she's going to
put them on the screen and I think
you'll see what I'm about to talk about
good evening within hours Sydney will be
in the grip of much tougher restrictions
the premier clamping down on the Stop
and Delta outbreak with what she's
calling a no regrets policy and this is
why from a record 82 000 tests the state
today recorded 111 cases and tragically
the third covert death in this outbreak
a man aged in his 80s from the city's
Southeast across greater Sydney retail
shops will now close a small list of
essential stores can remain open
construction sites across the city shut
down and from midnight tonight 110
suburbs across Liverpool Fairfield and
Canterbury bankstown will be sealed shut
that's 900 000 residents who can't leave
their area even for work
am I do you tune into this show to go
what is that conspiracy theorist Dave
Rubin think that that guy's really gone
off the rails he's quite an alarmist and
he's making people crazy and none of the
stuff that he says makes any sense I
hope that's not why you're here but if
you watch that and you don't think
something is extremely wrong
um I I don't know what to make of you
nine hundred thousand people basically
locked in their house okay so that's one
thing did you catch the numbers there in
Sydney and by the way I was in Sydney
two years ago it was one of the best
days of my life truly it was the last
show that I did with Jordan Peterson we
did the Sydney Opera House which is that
iconic building if you've never seen the
Sydney Opera House go Google it when I'm
done with this it is one of the most
gorgeous theaters on the planet right
out there on the Harbor on the on the
long Boardwalk the theater I didn't even
know until we got there was a theater
not in the round where you're in a
circle but in a square basically so you
have audience on every side of you
behind you in front of you on the sides
it was an unbelievable will show it was
our only matinee show of the day Jordan
I was a beautiful day we walked down the
the pier there and hundreds of people
were coming up to us mostly coming up to
him and it was just such a wonderful
wonderful day I did that show and then
uh and then I had a family engagement
that was the last show that I did with
Jordan Sydney was just wonderful
Australia was wonderful I love the
people in Australia because they have
because they remind us what I would tell
them on stage you guys remind me of
Americans but you're like more fun
you're more Politically Incorrect you
know they're they're Crocodile Dundee
Fosters Australian for beer you know
like like there's just like a zest for
Life there that seems to be being
squelched by these people so those
numbers that she just referenced in
Sydney these are just absolutely
incredible there were
8 82 000 tests in Sydney 82 000 tests
111. came back positive 82
000 tests 111 came back positive one
person died and he's in his 80s and now
Sydney is going into complete lockdown
due to as they said the premier's policy
which is the No Regrets policy
um there might be some regrets that
we're going to continue to ruin people's
lives and we're going to continue to
break down the very fabric of society
and make sure that people don't talk to
each other don't stop and talk to each
other and share information with other
citizens what are you some sort of
crazed lunatic
this is crazy stuff I mean I I look I
need some more context about what's
happening in Australia I know I have a
big viewership in Australia guys let me
know in the comments section like what
in the world is going on there 82 000
tests 100 come back positive one guy
dies he's in his 80s and you shut down a
city one of the most spectacular cities
on on this planet
someone explained that to me like just
craziness we're seeing this craziness in
Australia we're seeing this craziness in
Canada
we're seeing some version of this
craziness come back here in California
Los Angeles with the mass mayonnaise by
the way for the record last night I went
to a restaurant it was David's birthday
I took David and his mom out for dinner
and I walked in without a mask they came
in without a mask it was fairly obvious
that the people at the restaurant were
not thrilled with us but actually nobody
said anything and we sat down and we had
a perfectly fine dinner so I know I'm uh
I'm a real Rebel I'm a rebel all right
let's talk about socialism because that
perhaps is what this is all about that
we are just watching governments
worldwide centralized power they are
centralizing power against their free
individual citizens that's what seems to
me to be what the result of the virus of
kovid has done that that's the virus I'm
really worried about I'm not worried
that much about the virus that can get
people sick and of course it can I am
much more worried about the virus of
socialism and Marxism and communism that
has is going to have this Elite Class
over ruling over everybody else well you
guys all know Nicole Hannah Jones she is
the creator of the 16 19 project which
was the New York Times backed project
where in essence the argument of the
1619 project is that the founding of
America is not really the values of 1776
and individual rights and freedom and
the and the Constitution Etc et cetera
it really is that the founding of the
project was
1619 that slavery and racism are the
driving forces behind the history of
America now ironically this was done as
what was what we were told was a piece
of historical fact and actual journalism
uh Nicole Hannah Jones has had to
retract a bunch of things from 1619
project and no serious academic as far
as I know is taking any of this stuff as
fact well now there's some audio leaking
out this is Nicole Hannah Jones back in
2019 talking about Cuba and socialism
and I'm gonna link it to what's
happening of course in Cuba right now
and then to some of our wonderful
progress socialist politicians of the
day take a listen to this is there are
there candidates right now or even just
places that you think have a viable and
sufficiently ambitious integration
agenda and if so what what is it
that laughs out a lot right yeah I mean
one let me just
um I I'm definitely not an expert on uh
race relations internationally
um and
it's also hard to look at countries that
didn't have you know large institutions
of slavery and compare them to United
States
the answer is probably going to be
surprising that I'm going to give which
is if you want to see the most equal uh
multi-racial it's not a democracy most
equal multiracial country in our
hemisphere it would be Cuba
Cuba has the least inequality between
black and white people uh any place
really in the hemisphere that's uh I
mean the Caribbean
most of the Caribbean it's it's hard to
count because the white population a lot
of those countries is very very small
their countries run by black folks but
in places that are truly at least
biracial countries Cuba actually has the
least inequality
and that's largely due to socialism
which I'm sure no one wants to hear
Cuba has the least inequality and that's
largely due to socialism which nobody
wants to hear okay so she's basically
telling you this is two years ago now
she's telling you that she's a socialist
she almost accidentally calls Cuba a
democracy she stops that and her evil
cackle right at the beginning is
something and also the way these I don't
know if that was an NPR guy or is it
national post thing or something but the
way these interviews the way they talk
do you think that socialism is bad and
like what's up with Cuba and like can
you tell me more about that stuff like
what's wrong with these people can
someone explain to me what what happens
I don't know if it is that you it's the
soy you're like ingesting so much soy
and next thing you know you're talking
like this and you're like what's going
on and I can't really like think and
like I'm a socialist
um anyway so she basically admits she's
a socialist there what was interesting
is she talks about Cuba having the least
inequality between black and white
people so that's good but what she's not
telling you of course is that in a
socialist society the most inequality is
between the ruling class the ruling
class of Cuba right now which is doing
pretty good and the people the people
that are out of the street who are
begging
with American flags they've got nothing
and the ruling Elite have everything
that is what always happens in a
socialist society but she likes that
they actually like that inequality
because these these socialists these
marxists that we have now they're for
power and she knows she's going to be in
the ruling Elite Class so they're trying
to destroy our system they're trying to
destroy our democracy and the capitalist
system and I'll get to this in just a
sec they're trying to destroy because
they know they will be at the top of the
food chain so when they are pushing
socialism they're post they're pushing
socialism for the not for me which is
what all these giant corporations are
doing right like all these corporations
that have gone woke they want to still
profit off every damn thing there is
trust me I just went to Disneyland is it
Disneyland or Disney World here in uh
Disneyland yeah went to Disneyland and
it's like Disneyland here in in Anaheim
in California I've been to the other one
I've been to Disney World in Florida but
Disneyland it's like they go woke as
woke but you know you go to Disneyland
pretty much all they want is your money
right they want your money they want to
sell you a bunch of plastic [ __ ] for
your kids that they know they're never
going to use ever again while they're
selling you 12 dollar sodas to make you
fat and everything else so these people
are capitalists in their private life
what are they what is a capitalist in in
the bed what is it in the bed and the
sheets and the something you know what
I'm talking about something in the
sheets in the bed and the yeah the point
is they're [ __ ] all of us that's the
point all right so I bring this now to
AOC because this Wonder Woman of of
intellect uh she got into it with Sean
Spicer actually I'll be on Sean Spicer's
show on Newsmax uh later this afternoon
I'm pretty sure we're going to talk
about just this well AOC is now selling
a whole bunch of merchandise and she's
using the tools of capitalism to sell
merchandise so Sean Spicer took note of
that and and he tweeted this what was
the what was the line there he said that
AOC is using capitalism to push
socialism and of course that is true she
is selling products in our cap
capitalist Society while all day long
she push it pushes socialism that's
exactly what she's doing well she
responded and she said not sure if you
know this Sean but transactions aren't
capitalism capitalism is a system that
prioritizes profit at all at any and all
human slash environmental cost but for
what it's worth our shop is unionized
doesn't operate for profit and funds
projects like free tutoring free
programs and local organizing okay so
first off AOC you simply don't know what
capitalism is capitalism doesn't
prioritize cost and profit
at all expense capitalism maximizes
Freedom it maximizes human choice and
competition so not only do the best
products Bubble Up and the best human
Innovation bubble up but the best
businesses Bubble Up and part of that is
treating your people well I mean I talk
about this all the time I don't treat
the guys that are sitting in this room
well uh just out of the goodness of my
heart although I'm a pretty decent guy
that capitalism allows me to make
decisions as a businessman to go oh I
want to treat my employees well they'll
work harder that'll make a better
product more people will watch will make
more money good for me good for the
company good for the wider world I hope
capitalism has freed more people from
this the chains of servitude that
socialism and communism and Marxism have
brought so she's using the tools of
capitalism and then what she's saying
which is hilarious is she's saying we
don't operate for profit well I'd like
to find out where the profit ends up
going uh and it funds projects like free
tutoring food programs and local
organizing well all right AOC well then
I guess the government doesn't have to
do everything
Bernie's brain is about to freaking
explode are you saying AOC you can sell
stuff using the capitalist system and
then you can take the money from that
stuff and do what you want with it like
tutor kids and food programs and local
organizing the stuff that you want to do
with it boy what kind of system gives
you the freedom to do all that where
people can take their own hard-earned
money buy stuff from you then you can
use the money to phone fund programs you
like you know which system help me here
can one of you guys help me with this
one
capitalism but you they both said it at
the same time geniuses you know what you
guys can have guacamole on the Chipotle
today there you go because that's what
I'm all about rewarding good work okay
that's what we do around here anyway AOC
is just an absolutely ridiculous person
uh I did uh tweet at AOC I feel like I
nailed this one I don't show you my
tweets that often but I felt like I
nailed this one I retweeted her and I
said capitalism is about choice and
competition you Dullard good word many
companies are ethical and generous my
own business is included but glad you
finally came out against the economic
system America is based on now do the
Constitution and you will have fulfilled
your destiny and that links us to the
story that I just covered about Nicole
Hannah Jones and the 1619 project and
everything else as they undermine
capitalism as they undermine the free
market and our ability to to use our
money to buy things so that the people
we buy things from can use their money
to do whatever they want which is
exactly what you're doing right here AOC
as they undermine all that that's not
what this is really about in terms of
just undermining our economic system
it's undermining the entire thing
because if you think once they undermine
all the economic system that any of the
rest of our government our three
branches of government and any of the
rest of the way of life that we've all
come to love is going to stand well no
they're they're hacking away at the
foundation right now they're just
hacking at it hacking at it hacking it
and by the way that's why they love
lockdowns too I can actually link all of
the stories that we did today into one
one little conspiratorial bubble if you
will which is that they are hacking away
at everything they love lockdowns
because lockdowns in their minds further
prove that capitalism doesn't work right
and then we're gonna have to give people
Ubi we can't send them to work and they
don't like their jobs in the first place
and you don't pay them enough and now
they're all stuck at home because
there's a scary disease outside so let's
give them all Universal basic income and
they'll have just enough to survive and
everything else it's like they're
hacking away at everything if we are a
house on a beach with some poles they're
hacking away at those polls and at some
point the whole house is going to come
Crashing Down
I have nothing better to do the same
than save the world and that's what I
intend on doing and I'm going to fight
these people every step of the way
speaking of people that are fighting
these people every step of the way uh my
friend and and one of the key guys in my
red pilling Adventure Larry Elder is
running for governor of California as
you may have seen we posted part one
yesterday uh Larry was actually left off
the role of the 41 candidates that they
are putting on to run against Gavin
Newsom on an absolutely ridiculous
technicality related to his social
security number and some redactions he
is fighting it in court he should have
an answer as early as tomorrow I believe
that Larry Elder has all the right
answers
um he I think the interview is just
fantastic so the first part where we
talk about the the legal battle that
he's in just to get on the ballot we put
that up yesterday we did that just on a
phone because we just wanted to get it
out as soon as possible but part one in
essence it's part two I suppose of our
interview is up right now and of course
the full thing is already up at
reubenreport.locals.com oh and by the
way I am going to Freedom Fest for the
next three days so tomorrow which is
Wednesday we are doing our what is
normally our Thursday q a but I'm taping
it today did you get all that today
Tuesday I'm taping our Thursday q a for
Wednesday so if you want to submit
questions go right now to
reubenreport.locals.com and then we're
not going to have shows on Thursday or
Friday but I will be at Freedom Fest and
I know a bunch of you guys are going to
be there and maybe I'll do some stuff
off my phone and I know that ion Hersey
Ali is going to be there at Michael
Shermer is going to be there and I'm
sure a bunch of other good people so I'm
looking forward to that
um anyway keep fighting guys right I got
nothing better to do than save the world
see you tomorrow